the landscape is littered with body
parts antlers up to 20 pounds of bone
grown every year and discarded
male caribou start to grow antlers every
spring a transformation from bald to the
death
antlers are living tissue crisscross
with blood vessels and nerve endings
the sensitive fuzzy skin is called
velvet
each caribou has a signature pattern
which can grow back year after year
it would be no less wondrous if we were
to sprout a fresh arm the same of them
every year
[Music]
the tender velvet dies and is straight
away until it hangs in tatters
each male is now crowned with spikes of
unfeeling bone
fighting is one reason for the male
Caribous transformation and this helps
solve the mystery of why antlers shed
their velvet you can't fight a battle if
your sword can bleed and is sensitive to
the touch